over the course of five seasons Breaking
Bad told the tale of Walter White a man
whose cancer diagnosis drove him to cook
and sell meth now we're going to dig
deep and explain the story of the timid
chemistry teacher who finally broke bad
in the first episode of Breaking Bad
high school chemistry teacher Walter
White is diagnosed with terminal lung
cancer after finding out from Hank
Schrader his DEA agent brother-in-law
how profitable cooking meth can be Walt
teams up with a former student named
Jesse Pinkman to cook meth so that he
can make enough money to provide for his
family after he's gone and fortunately
Jesse and their batch of newly cook meth
are snatched up by a pair of dealers
named krazy-8
and Amelia the two forced Jesse to take
them to the RV where Walt and Jesse have
been cooking presumably to kill the two
and to take their materials Walt poisons
the two of them the krazy-8 survives
long enough that Walt is forced to kill
the meth dealer himself soon after
Walt's family pushes him to pursue
chemotherapy rather than just accept his
fate ultimately Walt agrees to seek
treatment even though the cost would put
his family even further into debt Walt
and Jesse make the partnership official
with a simple division of labor Walt
will cook while Jesse will sell the
chemistry is my realm I am in charge of
the cooking out there on the street you
deal with Jesse reaches out to a local
crime boss Tuco Salamanca to see if he'd
be interested in buying larger
quantities of the pair's high quality
meth but it's simply negotiations do not
go well Walt moves in to handle Tuco
using his chemistry skills to prepare an
explosion to intimidate Tuco and pressed
and amused Tuco agrees to work with Walt
and Jesse the to make a deal with to
code that they'll make meth for him to
sell while he pays them enough to make
it worth their while to keep his
identity a secret
Walt adopts the persona of Heisenberg
and it seems like Walter will be able to
keep his second job a secret from his
family unfortunately Tuco is about as
stable as a meth kingpin can be when
said kingpin also indulges in his own
product after a paranoid fit in which he
believes that the DEA is closing in on
Tuco kidnaps Walt and Jesse to force
them to continue cooking meth for him
while being held hostage Walt and Jesse
nearly managed to poison Tuka with ricin
the Tuco's mute wheelchair-bound uncle
Hector alerts him to their plan luckily
they're saved when Hank stumbles on the
Tuco and shoots him dead during a
shootout having barely survived their
run-in with the real criminal underworld
Jesse and Walt try to take a break from
the meth business
Jesse shacks up with a friend of his to
provide an alibi when the cops come
looking for him while Walt
feigns stress-induced amnesia to explain
his extended disappearance
while tries to reconnect with his family
when they become worried about his
health
after his fugue state but that only
brings up more underlying issues with
his pregnant wife Skyler meanwhile Jesse
finds himself kicked out of his aunt's
house and out of friends after the
double whammy of being kidnapped and
drawing the interest of the DEA on the
other side of the law
Hanks killing of Tuco leads to a sizable
promotion for him but it also causes a
heaping amount of stress and anxiety
after the shootout Walt and Jesse tried
to establish themselves as serious
contenders in the power vacuum created
by Tuco's death operating as cooks and
distributors within Tuco's former
territory a series of accidents leaves
Jesse with a reputation as a
cold-blooded killer which seems to
establish Heisenberg as a genuine power
player on the homefront things have
gotten complicated as a cover for all
his meth money Walt has been telling
Skyler that his former business partners
Gretchen and Elliott have been paying
for his cancer treatments but when
Gretchen finds out about the lie
she tells Skyler that she won't be
paying for any more therapy leaving Walt
to search for another cover story we'll
get through this they've already paid
for most of my treatment on top of all
of that Walt and Jesse end up attracting
attention from the law after badger one
of their meth dealers is arrested with
the help of Saul Goodman a local
criminal lawyer they devise a plan to
trick the DEA into arresting a fake
Heisenberg freeing badger and taking the
heat off Walt the plan goes smoothly
although Hank remains convinced that
something is wrong
everything seems to be going to plan
Walt is making money
Jesse's ongoing romance with his
neighbor and landlord Jane continues
even when she realizes that he's a drug
dealer and he realizes that she's in
recovery for addiction after one of
Jesse's drug dealer friends is killed by
a rival gang Jesse and Walt realized
they aren't cut out to manage a crew of
drug dealers
so with Saul's help Walt and Jesse find
the distributor for their surplus meth
the mysterious buyer Gus fring is a
fast-food franchise owner and model
citizen who uses his role as the public
face of los Pollos hermanos to disguise
his illicit activities those high
expectations extend to his employees and
Jesse shows up to a meeting hi Gus
doesn't think that Jesse is competent
enough to handle the work it turns out
he might have been right when Walt gets
noticed that Gus needs their drugs on
short notice he finds that Jesse is
completely incapacitated from his drug
use and unable to make the drop and
fortunately Walt is also needed at the
hospital where Skyler is in labor
delivering their daughter Walt
ultimately chooses to make the delivery
missing the birth of his child but he
nets over 1 million dollars for him and
Jesse to split
however Walt refuses to pay Jesse his
share until he gets clean desperate for
cash after her father nearly takes her
to rehab
Jane blackmails Walt into giving them
the money immediately
Walt does but finds himself coming back
to check on Jesse and try to get him
help while shaking a sleeping Jesse Walt
accidentally knocks an unconscious Jane
onto her back and when she starts to
choke on her own vomit he watches her
die without interfering weeks later
incapacitated by grief Jane's father an
air traffic controller lets two planes
collide over the skies of Albuquerque
after the plane crash
Jesse lands in rehab blaming himself for
Jane's death and everything else while
Skylar's taking the kids and moved out
leaving Walt to contemplate what he's
still working towards Skyler finds out
the truth that Walt is a meth cook and
offers him an ultimatum agreed to a
divorce or she'll tell Hank nobody will
hear it for me but only if you grant me
this divorce and stay out of our lives
things get even more complicated when
Gus
shows up with a new offer three million
dollars for three months work and a
state-of-the-art laboratory while it
refuses in the moment the trouble is
arriving from Mexico in the form of
bloodthirsty twins looking to enact
vengeance on Heisenberg waltz attempts
to get out of the drug business aren't
exactly helped along by anyone Saul
wants him to go back to cooking while
Skyler is horrified by what he's already
done unbeknownst to Walt
Gus strikes a deal with the twins who
are Tuco Salamanca's cousins out for
revenge to keep well to live for Gus's
own purposes meanwhile Jesse makes his
own batch of meth offering to sell it to
Gus against Walt's wishes
Gus accepts the deal knowing that Walt's
pride would bring him back to the meth
cooking business prediction that's
ultimately proven right Walt accepts
Gus's offer and pushes Jesse out of the
business while Hank finds clues that are
starting to lead him to Jesse Walt's
feeling like a new man with zone condo
and a hidden laboratory for cooking meth
even better he's got a new
eager-to-please lab assistant Gael
bedecker who seems like a serious
upgrade compared to Jesse
unfortunately Walt's brought back into
Jesse's orbit when Hank accidentally
warns Walt that he's closing in on their
old RV Walt and Jesse managed to
distract Hank with a phony phone call
alleging that his wife Marie is in the
hospital things get even worse for Hank
when Gus forced a bargain with the twins
offers them Hanks life instead of
Heisenberg's on the basis that Hank is
the one who actually killed their cousin
Tuco believin Jesse to be behind the
fake phone call Hank attacks Jesse
savagely beating him after Jesse
threatens to use the illegal beating to
make Hanks life miserable
Walt tries to placate Jesse offering him
a job in the meth lab jesse accepts the
deal which means Walt has to fire Gael
the Salamanca twins attack Hank but the
DEA agent kills one and puts the other
in the hospital although he's wounded
himself Walt and Jesse resumed their
cooking for Gus although Jesse begins to
take some of the excess product in order
to sell it on the side with Walt making
plenty of money and Hanks hospital bills
stacking up Skyler offers to pay for his
recovery with cover story that Walt's
meth
is actually earnings from a gambling
habits but things never run smoothly for
long and breaking bad after getting
involved with Andrea a woman at his
Narcotics Anonymous meetings jesse is
horrified to discover that the drug
dealers who killed his friend last
season are also using Andrea's 11 year
old brother to sell Matt Schuyler now
fully aware of Walt's criminal
enterprise patches a plan to safely
launder their money through the carwash
that Walt once worked at meanwhile
Jesse's moving on the drug dealers first
by asking Walt to prepare ricin poison
then by threatening to kill them any way
that he can with or without Walt's help
his plan is interrupted by Gus fring
who's known about Jesse's plan the
entire time the three of them have a
meeting where Gus tells the drug dealers
to stop using children in response they
kill Andrea's brother and Jesse responds
by driving up with a gun of his own to
enact revenge he's saved by Walt who
kills the dealers putting his own
relationship with Gus at risk Jesse goes
into hiding while Walt begins to suspect
that Gale is operating under orders from
Gus to fully replicate Walt's meth
formula so the kingpin can get rid of
Walt's for good with the help of Saul
Walt lays a trap for Gus giving Jesse
enough time to kill Gale ensuring that
the drug lord won't be able to kill them
without crippling his meth operation the
plan more or less works the Gus responds
by isolating himself entirely from Walt
and Jesse instead all communication will
be handled by his fixer Mike Ehrmantraut
as a result both Walt and Jesse begins
spiraling into darkness
Walt decides to buy a gun Casey needs to
kill Gus before Gus kills him and while
dealing with serious guilt over killing
Gale Jesse starts throwing money to the
wind
Jesse's unhinged depressed behavior is
bad news for Mike and Gus so Mike begins
taking the young chemist on some of his
errand runs an attempt to provide a bit
more purpose to Jesse's life Jesse's not
the only one acting erratic though when
gales body is discovered law enforcement
assumes that he's Heisenberg and that
nearly throws Hank off the trail until
Walt's ego gets in the way and he
convinces his brother-in-law that Gale
wasn't such a genius
after all all this brilliance looks like
nothing more than just simple rote
copying still worried about Gus's
vengeance Walt convinces Jesse to kill
Gus with rice and hidden in a cigarette
but Jesse misses his opportunity
however Gus has other fish to fry
besides Walt as a meeting with the
cartel involves completing a
decades-long vendetta after Hector
Salamanca killed Gus's business partner
years earlier the cartel is soon
destroyed in an epic massacre and with
Jesse's useful has proven on the trip
Gus asks him to take over the lab and
Walt's dead
Gus then tells Walt two pieces of very
bad news first
Walt's out with the understanding that
the only reason he's even alive as due
to Jesse's intervention second Gus is
going to kill Hank for investigating him
with worst consequences for Walt and his
family if anyone interferes Andrea's Sun
bra ends up in the hospital with a
flu-like illness and Jesse finds out
that the ricin hidden in his cigarette
is gone he blames Walt thinking that he
poisoned the child Walt convinces him
that it was Gus and the two agree to
kill the drug lord ultimately succeeding
with the help of Hector Salamanca and
his explosive wheelchair
Gus is dead the underground laboratory
is destroyed and Walt and Jesse both
managed to survive however Gus kept a
laptop with security footage of the lab
and with Gus's death it's been
confiscated by the police
Walt teams up with Jesse and a reluctant
Mike now healed from his cartel shootout
to wipe the laptop and keep them all out
of jail the plan goes smoothly but their
use of a giant magnet accidentally
reveals some of Gus's hidden bank
accounts giving the police a fresh lead
on Frings secret meth Empire it's also
revealed that Walt really did poison
Brock in order to turn Jesse against Gus
and that Walt has no intention of
stopping his criminal activities you've
never told me that kid would wind up in
the hospital with Gus out of the way
Walt sees the potential for a
replacement in the criminal underworld
Gus ran a massive organization with
multi-state distribution and Walt
believes that he Jesse and Mike are just
the men who can fill his shoes with the
help of Lydia rodarte-quayle an
executive at band Racal an international
conglomerate with ties to Gus's old
organization the three men plan to take
over the distribution of Gus's empire
with Lydia Mike and Saul's help Walt and
Jesse start a new operation moving their
meth lab from house to house under the
guise of a pest removal company however
even though Walt is now the boss of a
huge business that comes with assorted
costs like payouts to the pest removal
company to his partners and to Gus's
former men serving prison sentences in
order to keep their silence meanwhile
Walt success in business comes with a
failure in his personal life Skyler is
becoming increasingly depressed and
horrified by Walt and Walt's own
separation between his Heisenberg
identity and his day-to-day life is
becoming blur when the DEA begins
tracking one of the key ingredients for
their meth business at Madrigal
Lydia offers them an alternative a
daring Train Robbery that if executed
properly will mean enough methylamine
for plenty of cooks in order to make the
operation go smoothly Walt and Jesse
bring in time one of the pest removal
employee
the robbery seems to go smoothly but it
ends in tragedy when the trio notice a
young boy watching them as they
celebrate the desert heist Todd
immediately shoots the kid which forces
the crew to dispose of the body and a
barrel full of hydrochloric acid
although the team manages to get away
with all the methylamine they could need
the boy's death weighs heavily on Jesse
when Mike tries to buy out of the
business on the basis that the increased
DEA surveillance is too much for him
Jesse tries to leave too however Mike's
buyer for his share of the methylamine
will accept all or none of it
since the offer is contingent on getting
rid of the blue meth that Walt makes
Walt refuses to give up on his criminal
empire since with Skyler becoming
increasingly horrified by him he has
nothing left but his money and his
criminal reputation Walt eventually
manages to convince the buyer to take
over as distributor for his men while
buying out Mike share of the methylamine
Mike agrees to continue paying for Gus's
imprisoned man out of his own share but
his plan is stymied when the DEA catches
lawyer making the money drops Mike is
forced to flee town but Walt refuses to
let him leave unless he gives up the
names of Gus's men so Walt can silence
them before they have a chance to talk
the two men argue and Walt shoots Mike
to death before remembering that Lydia
also has access to that information with
the help of Todd's uncle who runs a crew
of neo-nazis Walt has Gus's men killed
before Hank can get them to give up any
information on Heisenberg with his
business safe and Todd proving to be in
a definite lab assistant Walt rakes in
the cash for months before finally
retiring that is until Hank finds a book
given to Walt by Gale on the toilet and
finally connects all the pieces even
though Walt is retired with plenty of
money Hank is on his trail just before
leaving town to start a new life Jesse
realizes that Walt was actually behind
Brock's poisoning which sends him on a
crusade against his former partner Hank
picks Jesse up before he can burn down
the white household and the two join
forces to gather evidence to take out
walk together they trick Walt into
revealing where he
his drug money and desperate Walt calls
his former neo-nazi partners for help
the neo-nazis arrived kill Hank and
kidnap Jesse Walt goes into hiding in
New Hampshire but after seeing Elliott
and Gretchen Schwartz on TV denying his
involvement in the company he co-founded
he comes back to tie up his loose ends
he forces Elliott and Gretchen to
launder the rest of his drug money for
his family and he admits to Skyler that
everything he did was for selfish
reasons one more time that you did this
for the family he then heads to the
neo-nazi compound kills the skinheads
and ultimately saves Jesse's life in the
process dying of blood loss from a stray
bullet
Walt collapses in the neo-nazis meth lab
surrounded by chemical equipment as the
police arrive check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]